metro police is investigating a deadly
dog attack involving a terrier now it
happened at an apartment complex on
pennwood near valley view and d-i this
morning the victim now identified as
88-year-old joanne caffel nearly nearby
residents telling us that they were
shocked about what happened
that's terrible that's really terrible
we met carla jones tuesday afternoon and
was shocked to see the police presence
over a fatal dog attack it's so sad it's
like i'm scared for my dog now
i don't want to bring them out metro
police say officers were alerted about a
dog attack just after 9 30 tuesday
morning when they arrived to this
apartment complex on pennwood near
desert inn they found an older woman who
appeared to have been attacked by a dog
and died the dog involved in the attack
was located at a nearby residence a
short time after and was handed over to
animal control the city of las vegas
telling us the dog is a terrier type and
is being held at the animal foundation
as the investigation continues
the dog owner's information is unknown
at this time we're told the spring
valley area command patrol detectives
are leading this investigation